the Joe Rogan experience the the
education in health care those are the
two things that I think we can both
agree we need to invest money on and we
need to figure out some way to make that
more accessible yes yes and I don't
understand people that don't think that
and if that's what that is the strict
father mentality they just the only
thing that it makes sense to me is that
you don't want people who are kind of
half-ass in college just did that can
just get in I think that that comes up a
lot you hear about so-called free
college which is it's free it's we're
saying we're paying for it through
taxation really important to point that
out it's it's just not for everybody
that's okay I mean I think that that
that sometimes gets lost and yes there
are more and more jobs that require
college degrees even though you could
make the case maybe the college degree
is not actually necessary but it's a way
to sort of thin the herd of applicants
in order to just make hiring you know
more more practical but I do think that
it's okay to say that college isn't for
everybody but the same ideas that apply
to so-called free college meaning
college paid for through education
could apply to trade school they could
apply to retraining programs there's a
whole bunch of other ways that it could
be done yeah no I agree yeah I just the
college is not for everyone thing is
more true now than ever before
particularly with certain technology
studies you're learning things during
your four years at a university that are
just gonna be completely outdated by the
time you graduate in in what kind of
program for example Jamie what he did
with audio engineering oh I see okay you
went to school for audio engineering by
the time he got out it was all useless
yep but that was not a four year
bachelor's program right it is now oh it
is now oh yeah I when I went there it
wasn't available for that but since then
they have made that available and that's
awesome in the time that YouTube has
made basically education free for a lot
of people sure so I mean I think with
that the issue is in my mind that when
you consider the cost relative to the
earnings potential as you pointed out
when you name about $68,000 a year or
you know I went over this i guest taught
at Boston College and I think it was
like 64,000 all something like
that depending on what field you're
going into it's it's almost impossible
to pay that off ever yeah so some at
some point something needs to change and
this kind of gets us into the
technological automate automate and an
unemployment stuff of what happens as
computers and Technology start to
replace jobs and that's where I think
there's a pretty clear line between a
free-market capitalist a social democrat
like myself and actual socialism like
what should happen with the gains that
come from those technological
advancements but as far as the education
piece is concerned it's completely
unsustainable the way it is now
[Applause]